and thank you for joining us on this
friday night at 11 i'm bryan loftis a
normal day in the job for a local lyft
driver takes an awful turn after he's
attacked in his own car now he is
sharing that story to warn others and
hopefully stop something similar from
happening again sasha loftis has a story
you'll only see right here on 8 news now
brian the lift driver i spoke with says
he was just doing his job when things
spiraled out of his control now he wants
other ride share drivers and riders to
be aware
i was scared to death a routine night
behind the wheel turned into a moment
marcelo smith will never forget i
thought i was going to end right there
he says he was picking up a lyft ride
downtown in december when he was
assaulted now he's nervous to go back to
work i said
hey man brother remember i was telling
you to keep your mask on smith said he
asked his riders to put their masks on
which is company protocol according to
lift's website that's when he tells us
both men became agitated so he canceled
the ride and asked them to get out of
his car
but their anger only escalated he said i
told you we had the effort
mask and he started to strangle me smith
described how he says one of the
passengers reached into his car and
attacked him leaving him overwhelmed and
shaken he's like this on me and like for
12 seconds police later identified the
suspect and say this case was reported
and investigated as a misdemeanor
battery and there's no word on whether
charges were filed people get drunk they
actually throw up in the car
but to be strangled now smith says he's
just hoping to send a message to other
drivers and riders to always keep an eye
out and stay safe you'll try to kill me
because until you protect yourself and
me
now i reached out to lyft about this
situation they said they are looking
into the incident and will get back to
me reporting live tonight sasha loftis
live local now